hello and thank you all for coming to
tonight's communications forum my name
is Stephanie Caen I'm the director of
the forum and will be the moderator this
evening we have these talks roughly
three times a semester we would love it
if you all would let us know how to
reach you with that sign-up sheet so we
can let you know about future talks we
will not spam you you will only get six
emails a year or three a semester so
it's not very onerous our next forum is
in two weeks from tonight is that right
Chris I think two weeks from tonight
April 26th when Kevin Young who is the
new yorkers poetry editor and the
director of a center of african-american
history and culture at the new york
public library will be here talking
about his new book bunk about the rise
of hoaxes and fake news and the way
communications forms run is we will have
a conversation for roughly an hour at
which point we'll open it up to all of
you for roughly another hour and that's
pretty much it as far as ground rules go
so without further ado let me introduce
our panel to my immediate left is Stuart
Stevens a political consultant who's
worked on presidential campaigns for Bob
Dole and George W Bush served as the
lead strategist for Mitt Romney's 2012
campaign and helped elect more governors
in US senators than any GOP consultant
working today
Stevens is also an author and founding
partner of the consultancy firm
strategic partners in media he has
served as a strategist and media
consultant to Governor Tom Ridge
senators chuck Grassley john mccain thad
cochran roger wicker Dick Lugar and many
others he's also written script for
Northern Exposure
and is has written novels and also does
some journalism including a very very
memorable piece for outside
like 15 years ago now right yeah yeah we
can arrange that next
Jennifer Nasser is the founder of
conservative women for a better future a
nonprofit organization dedicated to
electing more conservative women in the
Northeast
she's also the former chairman of the
Massachusetts Republican Party and
during her tenure Republicans won the US
Senate seat held by Scott Brown
otherwise known as the Kennedy seat up
until that point right and and doubled
their ranks in the Massachusetts House
of Representatives and then on the end
doc tell Daniel Barca is that your last
name right
Berkeley is president of veterans for
responsible leadership a nonpartisan
political action committee that supports
veterans who have demonstrated integrity
and rational thought as they run for
positions in local state and federal
elections he served for seven years as a
member of the Naval Special Warfare unit
otherwise known as Navy SEALs and is
currently a faculty member and an
emergency medicine doctor at the
University of Vermont so I thought I'd
start out just by asking all of you how
you got into politics what brought you
into into politics in short when we
start with you my family was close to a
wonderful man named William winter who I
had the distinction of working in all
this campaigns losing him mates for
governor three times of loss and then
finally I quit working for him and he
got elected there you go
but he was he went against the last of
creationist and I just found politics
just absolutely then and mr. simply
everyone was pretty much a Democrat and
the Democrats were Eastland Dennis and I
gravitated toward working for Republican
spectacular was the first because they
were certain running against that
machine and politics was funny this is
what you sort of start working on one
side you end up staying on that side so
that that's how okay Jen so I grew up in
New York and my dad died when I was 10
of a massive heart attack and I wanted
to go to school to be a doctor
so I wanted to be a cardiologist and I
decided it was a really good idea to go
to Stony Brook University which has
medical school and got there and
realized I probably wasn't as smart as I
thought I was it was when I if I was at
a school that wasn't committed to
Sciences and during the summer between
my sophomore and junior year I was
working in my local village hall and
it's going to get signatures on
petitions and I said for who why do you
want to know what you're signing well he
wasn't asking me he was just saying that
he was getting them and he goes oh great
made a phone call and then 30 seconds
later I'm on the phone with this woman
who said come to my house tonight and
get the petition forms and so in New
York I lived in Nassau County which is
still kind of the last bastion of GOP
political machines and I went to her
house and it was everyone from Al
D'Amato and George Pataki
and I went out and I grew up in this
town and I worked in our donnelly did I
work in the village hall in the summer
but I worked in our local one of the
local restaurants throughout all of high
school and college and I went and I got
maybe eight forms 50 signatures and I
went back the next day and I hand them
to the woman and she goes wait you got
this all done I'm like yeah I know
everyone in town so he had another 50
and I got those and I brought those in
so I collected the most signatures of
anyone in my town I was 19 years old I
had I was going to school to be a doctor
I went back to school and I changed my
major to be a Poli Sci major and then I
graduated from college and my first job
was with the state senator and then that
was kind of it and then I moved here I
have three daughters and Donald Trump
was elected president that's all right
succinct into the point okay so one
thing I was interested in is what all of
your perspectives were during the
campaign Stuart I know you like most of
the world thought that Trump didn't have
a chance in the primary and then
probably didn't have a chance in the
general election conventional wisdom
certainly seemed to be wrong but as this
was unfolding Dan I don't know if you
identified as a Republican but this was
a party that both of you have been
identified with for your adult lives
what was that experience like seeing
this figure sort of take over the party
so out of the 16 candidates I think I
would have voted for like 13 and I knew
I knew it got bad when I was on a plane
with someone that I knew from
Massachusetts and going down to Florida
and I spent three hours telling her how
Ted Cruz would be a better president
than Donald Trump like my politics he on
your list of 13 no I mean my politics
are nowhere near Ted Cruz's so it's like
if I was saying that then you know
things were getting bad and I also have
three daughters and I just couldn't
believe it to me it was so much right
I've been a Republican since I was able
to vote and the man number one wasn't a
real Republican I mean he he was a
registered Democrat and then just became
a Republican all of a sudden because he
knew he couldn't win as a Democrat and
then his morals and values oh wait
I'm sorry there are no morals and values
and so that was really concerning and
he'd never seemed I mean growing up in
New York and knowing people who knew him
he didn't pay his bills he you know
consistently was borrowing
I mean it's so like if you look at what
the Republican Party is and it's the
party of family that's not you know what
he was embodying the party of fiscal
responsibility not the party not what he
was embodying and so it was really
upsetting to me and and they just
continued to go I mean with the day of
the Billy Bush right expose I was
horrified I just said that's it I mean
it's one thing that he does what he does
but it's another thing that he's on a
live mic and he gets caught saying it
and then it's just locker room talk I
don't know guys
that do that right look a lot of people
were wrong about Donald Trump 2016 but
arguably I was the most strong I think
that Donald Trump has always benefited
dan and I were talking about this
driving down from Vermont from the
inability to imagine him winning and I
think in the primary the consensus of
these other candidates and I have a lot
of friends working in those and I've
done five of these presidential
campaigns and this nominating process is
always fraught they had the not insane
idea that I all you have to do is get
along with Donald Trump because
obviously the Republican Party snuck him
in the Hamid a Donald Trump so you just
want to be one-on-one and you're not
gonna be Donald Trump and you're gonna
win so hints all of this effort beating
up on each other not to be Donald Trump
which turned out to be a tragic flaw and
he benefited from it I think in the
general election he benefited from a lot
of protest votes to didn't really
imagine him being president but I
personally think when he came out for
the Muslim band that the party rights
should have treated him the way that we
treated Todd akin in Missouri who was a
Senate candidate in 2012 who said these
horrible things about women and rape and
the party just said okay this may cost
us a Senate seat but we can't stand
behind this and Aitkin lost I think he
should have done that when he a Muslim
ban is nothing but a religious test and
he should have stepped forward and said
we're not going to do this you can run
we can't stop you from running but the
Republican Party as long as I'm leading
it it's not going to stand behind you
Governor Romney gave that tremendous
speech that he gave on Trump once you
don't do that you just sort of get
caught in these constant bargains with
yourself okay he's not Hillary Clinton
okay
I will get this judge or we'll get that
and it's just this I think really
unfortunate process and where people
forget about Faust is it's not just the
solar so the devil but devil didn't
deliver you didn't get what you wanted
me and I think now that's being played
out and then during the campaign if you
had time to sort of think about politics
with three incredibly young girls at
that point did you could you see
yourself sort of getting engaged in this
way or was this something that happened
as soon as you know didn't after the
election no if I'm not a week after the
election really but you know the no and
just like everyone else and you know we
didn't think he was gonna win you know I
was not a huge Hillary Clinton supporter
either but leaps and bounds above you
know that I thought most people would
see it in that way as well
so now this was never something I
anticipated or playing down or right
right but so that your group that really
grew out of a Facebook group why don't
you yeah so I mean we so you know people
complain on Facebook all the time that's
that's what happened so you know via far
L came about because my Naval Academy
buddies and I were complaining about
this on Facebook and this is after the
elections is after the election you know
we kind of floated the idea of starting
a Facebook group which pretty quickly
got a couple hundred members and then
you know we decided to incorporate and
so we incorporated as a you know as a as
a pact and you know which took about
four minutes of research and probably
twice that much time to actually do the
paperwork and you know it's it's sort of
started to resonate the thing that
surprised me about Trump I mean Trump
Trump voters are by and large the parts
of the country where he does well our
areas that provide a lot of people to
the military and you know you say you
have this selection bias where you know
people in the military are generally
predisposed to like guys like Trump or
you know and guys like something meaning
well you know like the luster the
machismo or yeah I think I think there's
not you know Stuart and I were talking
about this and way down to I think
there's something to you know parts of
red states in this country part you know
and it is the red states that contribute
people to the military you know I'm from
Massachusetts and we're pretty close to
last and you know having people sign up
and you know these parts of the country
that contribute a lot of people to the
military you know they really do you
know come from more of an honored
culture you know there's there's much
more comfort with with combat with you
know kind of these these notions of
masculinity that you know that you know
for better or for worse exist and those
people a lot of times are you know gonna
vote for someone with a little bit of a
chip on their shoulder and that's how
that's what I think happened in this
election I think that this election was
one big fu to the establishment sort of
speak you talked I mean the other day
when we were on the phone you talked
about how in during the Clinton
presidency how there was this kind of
revulsion at his at Clinton's lies
surrounding Monica Lewinsky I think you
said something like you know Trump
topside every day before breakfast so
how does that sort of reconcile itself
where does the revulsion against the
against dishonesty how does how is that
so easily trumped by the sort of much is
mo the honor by that sentiment so I
think
I think there's two competing and this
is the entire idea of VF RL you know to
back up in a second what I'm what I'm
trying to do what we're trying to do is
convince veterans not to vote for Trump
and we're gonna do it in states where
there are a lot of veterans and where
the margins were pretty narrow and
specifically that's Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and in Michigan and you
know we're talking and specifically
we're gonna do it but he's taken public
information from the VA about where
people are using the GI Bill and when
you look at the numbers there's enough
veterans enrolled at colleges to swing
to it out of those three states right
now using the GI Bill so what I'm
counting on you know back to your
question is that the way I view it is
there's sort of two competing honor
codes and you know honor is you know I'm
kind of a I'm a cynical guy of a cynical
sense of humor but you know mill the
military culture of Honor is the is why
people our soldiers are able to go into
combat and give their life for one
another that integrity honesty strength
courage that's an honor code all right
it's competing that you know for folks
from you know red states and in some
ways it's competing against a somewhat
overlapping honor code that they grew up
with that is you know maybe not as
prominent in you know a place like
Massachusetts or Cambridge or something
like that but you know if you if you
spend time around you know kind of a
working-class environments I think you'd
be familiar with it so what has
surprised me about the Trump voters is
not how many Trump voters you know sorry
brother how many military folks working
for Trump what's surprising to me is how
many military folks don't like Trump
which actually is assigned to me that
that kind of second honor code that you
know people are inculcated when they go
to boot camp when they go to Iraq for a
year and walk foot patrols in falesha
that that's more powerful at least with
some people so that's the idea right
Jennifer you said that during the
campaign you thought well clearly this
is he's not gonna succeed because he's
not a Republican he doesn't embody
fiscal responsibility you know family
values moral values religious tolerance
and when we were again talking to Stuart
I think you raise the point that maybe
that is what a Republican is now I mean
if he's the head of the party maybe we
need to rethink what it means to be a
Republican in 2018 what are your
thoughts about that
no I'm holding firm in my convictions in
my party no I think it was honestly I
think that the u.s. is still a very
racist sexist society I mean you know I
think it's it's it's not as intelligent
as everyone tries to make this out to be
it's very clear this guy is a racist
sexist pig right and and and he was
running against a woman and there's a
large portion of the country that's
looking at it saying I don't want a
woman one too we just had eight years of
a black man who is a Democrat so we
don't want another Democrat we already
had him we went different we're not
doing different again we're going back
to the old white guy who has the same
thoughts as we do everywhere else except
for California and the Northeast
I mean basically that's what happened
and so because it's amazing when you get
out of the Northeast it's even amazing
in Boston I tell friends all the time if
you sit at any restaurant in the city
and sit near the bar area and sit near
some millennial like that not young
Millennials like the 30 something year
olds that are you know nicely dressed
they love Trump they're making money
they have good jobs they live in Boston
they're super educated there's nothing
wrong that's going on there
you know and then you've got the center
of the country where these people you
know are I think very differently and so
I think that that is it's it's it was so
over thought as to why he wouldn't be
elected but it's so simplistic as to why
it was elected so I don't think that
that's what the party is I just think
that unfortunately the RNC and I blamed
ranks a lot took their eye off the ball
let it happen
no one had any leadership there no one
was the parent and no one said no one
flapped him around a little bit everyone
just let him go but getting back to the
notion of what the party is I mean Trump
outside of how people are voting Trump
has certainly in his policies also
gotten huge swathes of the party
leadership to go along with things that
you know three years ago would have been
an athlete to them but you don't
necessarily agree because I think that
there are different buckets I think that
there are people who really hate Trump
in the part in the Republican Party
there are people who really hate Trump
there are people who really like Trump
and then there are people in the middle
and the people in the middle either
don't approve of his him as a person but
they like his policy or they don't
approve of him as a person but they like
that he's different they like that he's
edgy they like that he's the guy that's
on fire and and really shaking things up
and so I don't think that the party
changed I think it was more of a I think
it was everyone's I was off the ball
this guy came in no one thought he was
going to win and then he got in there
and I mean the people who look it does
anyone here think that we don't need
term limits that the people in Congress
have any sort of I was gonna say listen
no one in Congress has a set of balls
right that's why they're in Congress and
they're not out working because if
they're there they're safe and they're
protected if they actually have to get a
real job then they have a real boss
who's going to hold them their feet to
the fire and we as a society have let
our elected officials think that they
are celebrities
because they think that they're
celebrities they're untouchable so I
mean that's the mess that goes on right
so we throw everyone out and then 20 20
comes the thing is there's no one to run
against him on the Democratic side so
this just keeps on going
no in 2020 you mean in 2020 right well
yeah
although at this point in the cycle and
to that for the 2008 election I don't
think anyone would have predicted the
rock Obama was gonna get elected so it's
but just which is just to say it's hard
too hard to say sir what are your
thoughts about about how what the
identity of the Republican Party under
trauma I'm in a pretty dark place about
it I joined the party or it was drawn to
the party as a place to believe in the
character counts that personal
responsibility is important strong on
Russia the debt matters and I look now
and it's I don't know where all that
went it was as if those were just
marketing slogans and okay so it didn't
work I mean if you say Chevrolet's a
heartbeat of america or you're not
really saying there's like a heart and
said of chevrolet said okay you get will
just say something else to me I actually
believe those things and I worked for
people that I felt shared those values
and a lot of them did I mean we were
talking here I first came to
Massachusetts to work for Bill well when
he ran in 1990 first Republican governor
elected in 25 years and it I don't know
where that party is gone and but a more
troubling I don't know how you get it
back I don't know how you unsay the
things that Trump has said and I think
the future not the demographics are
destiny but Trump's base or
non-college educated white voters and
Rhoni white voters right I mean it's
there's sort of environment and wealthy
though there's fewer wealthy people
right but twenty years ago that was uh
non-college educated white voters for
sixty percent of the electorate now it's
thirty percent and it's rapidly
declining so I really see Trump as a
triumph of white grievance not that
everyone voted for him was drawn by that
but I think that the ability just
numerically having said in these rooms
and banging my head against the wall so
many times to try to get to a
presidential win I think the future of
the poker party nationally is very bleak
if you can't appeal everything we said
after a 2012 election if you can't
appeal to more non-white voters I look
at the Republican Party I kind of think
of lying word-processing in 1979 things
are great
so I don't I don't really know where the
party goes do you still see yourself as
being in the GOP yes we know wouldn't
let Donald Trump drag me out of a party
and I work for people who I I've never
found the candidate that I agreed with
anything but one that's good you don't
agree with one spouse with everything um
but I think that there are a lot of
candidates out there that still have
those values the question is sort of
where is the center of gravity I mean
when the RNC endorses Rory more where
are we
Senatorial Committee didn't but the RNC
did yeah
and it's depressing to look that 66% of
white voters in Alabama voted for or
ignore I mean we were saved by
african-americans not for the first time
and really african-american women to be
truthful I find that just incredibly
sobering and I don't know where are you
once you've been for Rory more I'm not
sure how you get back any sense of
decency so if you have the National
Committee supporting anymore you have at
the direction of the president the only
reason they do is because I'm sure right
but you have the president who's the
titular head of the party you have the
RNC supporting Roy Noire you have what
Trump says not only about Muslims but
about any number of groups about any
number of things what would it take for
you to feel like this was no longer your
party I mean it seems like you've just
listed a number of things that are
beyond the pale oh it's a bad question I
[Music]
you know I spent a lot of years actually
fighting for these things and look I'm
not trying to pretend I'm that we were
perfect I mean I work for George Bush I
went down to 99 I wrote a book about the
campaign we had bad days and we public
played on the dark side sometimes more
than we should have but we at least
aspired to something you can be proud of
and on our best days I think we came
closer to that I think there were a very
personality-driven country and absent an
alternative person emerging it's
difficult to imagine how you get out of
it but I think how you get out of where
we are now right for the party in hell
but I think it will happen I think it
will take someone who we can't name
now running and winning and then I think
there really needs to be sort of a truth
and reconciliation moment or come to
grips with what has been said and a sort
of ugliness that has been made
legitimate in the current moment dan I
know you're obviously not in active
military now I know I found it hard
sometimes so just pick up the paper but
certainly hard to pick up Twitter
because I'm worried every day that
there's gonna be a new conflict in some
part of the world because Trump was
constipated that morning or whatever the
case is and so fired off some incendiary
tweet do you do you have any sense of
what the effect of his when he threatens
North Korea when he says that we're
gonna we're gonna bomb away Telegraph's
his intentions about Syria whether or
not even thoughts run that do you have
any sense of what effect that is having
on people serving today the thing that I
think you know maybe many people don't
understand is everyone in the military
nowadays is a volunteer and everyone in
the military now it is once wants to
work you know so when you have when you
get rid of the draft in 1973 you're
stuck with the fact that your military
wants to go to war all the time and
there are pluses and minuses to that but
that's you know so doesn't it you know I
think your your question is does it have
a an impact on you know what we call
morale of the troops kind of thing not
really I don't I don't think we can hang
that on on Trump particularly I mean I
think there's Lord knows there's enough
to talk about with Donald Trump but I
don't think necessarily that's one of
the issues and so when you were serving
you and would have preferred to be in
combat then
yeah yeah I mean I think you know I mean
I was I was a Navy SEAL like Navy SEALs
one of the great war thanks that's just
the truth right right I as I got no
again on its group one of the things I
was struck by listening to him speak
with some of his other naval grads is
how you were saying that when you were
at the academy it's not that you were
tell to be apolitical but to be an a
part nonpartisan but to be a partisan
not to be at all involved can you just
speak to that I think that's a
fascinating concept well I think you
know if you have a professional a
professional military you know the the
you were your you know you there's a
whole UCMJ there's a whole you know
Uniform Code of Military Justice that
you know you one is not allowed to you
know exercise one's First Amendment you
know wearing a uniform you know you you
the expectation is that you're at least
not publicly you know go about and kind
of espouse political views or support
for political candidates and you know
sort of as it should be and I think I
think the best you know officers in our
military
you know really try to you know try to
live that you know there's a reason you
don't hear the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff you know weighing in on
on Donald Trump so looking ahead then to
to 2020 what do you see is happening
both in terms of on in federal elections
and also in a presidential election sort
I know you've made the case before that
for if a president does not accept
federal spending limits as I assume that
Trump will not I think the last
president who was defeated who did not
accept them was Hoover is that correct
yeah but he had a bad year yes
so something to most people don't we
just talk about the research you know
post-watergate we passed federal funding
for presidential elections we had sort
of a cockamamie system for the primaries
it sort of died out and no one listened
we have understood it but for the
general election we had a system and
when you accepted a nomination literally
when you walked off the stage
after giving your speech accepting
nomination at the convention you got a
check and exchange for that check you
agreed not to raise or spend beyond that
amount of money it was around 82 million
dollars that started in 76 and it went
through 2008 everybody did it it was
actually literally a cheque I remember
the same I can't believe what I heard
was it like a big like Publishers
Clearing House that's why in Bush were
we move the convention up I mean we move
the Commission's back because we realize
you're gonna get the same amount of
money for W yeah well in 2000 way of the
convention in July and then you know in
2004 we had it as late as possible you
have to do it 60 days for the election
because you're gonna get the same amount
of money you want to condense the amount
of time you have to spend that money
now the conventions are late for no
reason it's sort of a legacy as should
change but so in 2012 in 2008 Barack
Obama and I think it's one of his most
unfortunate legacies decided that he
would not accept federal funding after
saying he would everybody said they took
federal money it was sort of a given now
if you read then with his campaign
managers Dan now I'm blanking yeah no no
no they wrote the audacity to win then
yeah
David book yeah he's pretty honest about
it if you're he's a good book it's not a
long blogger he basically says we did it
could we knew we could get away with it
and we could raise ungodly amounts of
money so John McCain stayed in a federal
funding system seven he had 83 million
Barack Obama spent 750 million on the
day of election Barack Obama had 33
million dollars cash on him which was
like at that point you know you spend
like stupid money it's like the question
becomes not like if I spend this while I
get votes it becomes like well I spend
this will I lose votes so they still had
33 million dollars they couldn't get rid
of on Election Day McCain only had 83 to
run his whole campaign so in the history
of a federal finance performance
generalist wants something sort of the
genies out of the bottle it's hard to
get it back so I don't think anyone is
going to accept federal funding again
I'm a great advocate having done
elections under both systems one of the
things federal funding did was level the
playing field it was intended to do that
and it actually worked
so Reagan wins beats an incumbent
president under the the level playing
field federal funding you have Clinton
beat under federal funding under level
playing field so if you just go to the
next election whoever emerges from the
Democratic primary is probably going to
be broke you're always broke when you
come out of the primary it would be true
if Hillary Clinton's president incumbent
President Barack Obama raised about 1.2
billion if you really kind of get out of
bed and get working on it you ought to
be able to raise close to two billion
dollars so you're gonna have to
incumbent president with I mean who
knows the Trump but could could with the
potential to raise close to two billion
dollars put it that way no one says no
if you're calling for the incoming
president to raise money it's easiest
job in the world versus someone who's
broke so that's tough now maybe money
doesn't mean as much as we thought it
did but still it's it's a very very
difficult situation and I thought after
going through this that we really in a
way had the law of unintended
consequences which always happens with
campaign finance that in many ways we
probably abolished the four-year term
when we let federal funding go away
it comes in a do journey basically
become today your turn because it's
gonna be so difficult to be now what's
it sure he thought I mean one other
thing that you had both in 1980 and 1988
was primary challengers
yes Vernon guts the other of he's just
in a poli-sci sense one of the
indicators that an incumbent president
will lose is being primary so even
buchanan primary Bush in 292 hurt bush
certainly Kennedy primary and Carter you
would have to say hurt had Bernie
Sanders run against Barack Obama in 2012
it would have heard there's nothing else
you're gonna spend a lot of money and it
would have hurt I think it's very
important for lots of reasons to Donald
Trump the primary it'll be very very
very very difficult to beat him but I
think there's always races worth winning
worth running even if you go into it not
winning and that's what happen with
Scott Brown's and I'm doing to those
races and you end up winning who do you
see is is potentially challenging I mean
given how many national figures have
sort of gone along with them who do you
see challenging him well senator flake
is out there right
my old pal and client John Kasich those
would be the two most obvious that's
right anyone and the same exact thing I
mean I think no one's gonna no one will
beat Donald Trump but my view right now
is no one beats Donald Trump at all
Donald Trump is the president for the
next six years
just because cyanide tablets are right
outside the door I know my daughter came
to me the morning after the election in
2016
walked into my room 5:30 in the morning
I was on TV all night I was like zombie
I had to get ready get back on and she
goes are we moving to Australia
I'm a Republican I think that was pretty
impactful I think he needs to be primary
because I think that people like us need
some hope and for him to get battered a
little bit but you know from the
Democratic side all I keep hearing from
my insider Democratic friends is that
they want Joe Biden so it's like that's
great put up Joe Biden and Trump wins
again you know so it's not it's gonna be
very tough for him to lose but I think
that there are Republicans that are
really frustrated me and you see what
happened like you know chuck Grassley
Marco Rubio we're on TV talking about
you know if Trump goes and and tries to
fire Mueller you know what what their
what their position is and that they
don't think that that should happen and
that there's a joint agreement to make
sure that he's protected I think that
you're you start seeing when some more
monkey businesses play it like tax
reform everyone wanted that you know and
immigration reform whether they wanted
it out loud or not they do want it right
so I mean there are certain things that
they have to play in their districts and
say things for their constituencies but
maybe innately they want so they'll let
that go but I think once he starts
monkeying around with the judicial
system then he's gonna find himself in
hot water
okay that's feeling way you get rid of
him by the way because if he's impeached
he he resigns or you know the the you
know worst case scenario happens and and
so pushing that and pushing back against
that a little bit I mean certainly the
Trump brand in elections that have
happened over the past 12 months Federal
Elections does not seem to be doing very
well I mean you know losing a Senate
seat in Alabama
is is pretty tough unless unless you're
a disgusting individual then then you
can lose I mean if you're a pedophile
you're gonna lose well I mean the
reality is if you run if you're on the
night I mean the 2016 race 100 times
Hilary Clinton wins 90 at least I mean
if you just do the numbers I mean he was
able to overpower we go to one of those
alternate use well he said he was able
to over perform just enough with rifle
right and she underperformed with
non-white voters just enough now why
there's infinite fascinating studies and
books about this and then he basically
came down to probably four counties
where this happened and to me that's not
an indication that the politics of
relying on white voters is good politics
I think it's it's certainly morally
bankrupt but to me it's sort of like you
have a bunch of drinks at a party you
drive home safely you get home safely
and you decide that alcohol helps you
drive better like probably the wrong
conclusion just because it happened
doesn't mean that it's causative so I
think that there what you've seen I
think is re-energized Democratic base
and I think you're gonna if this is what
I think what Dan is doing is so
important to have just around the
margins enough of those who voted for
Trump who will be motivated by other
values they have I think is very
important but I have to say also you
know in those elections that that
Republicans have lost and let's use the
special election special election so
I'll use Roy Moore I I think other than
us being racist and sexist women white
educated women Hillary Clinton because
I'm in that age group that 35 to 55 year
old age group of educated white women
looked at Hillary Clinton and said you
are not the woman who's trying to help
us and you're the one and what you're
not you're not lifting the glass ceiling
you're lifting it for you and you're
opening a little window for your own
self but you're not trying to get the
rest of us up with you and so we're your
staff
furs where your campaign workers where
your daughter's friends but we're not
women that you are putting on the bench
to run after you and so I think that
people women voted for Trump because all
of us have worked for a man like Donald
Trump
we all understand how to navigate that
system and we've all worked for a woman
like Hillary Clinton and all said we're
never working for another woman like
that again and so I think what happened
was white women said I'd rather go with
him because I know that beasts rather
than working for that [ __ ] I mean
that's basically you know being in that
being in that realm of those women
that's how women really felt they were
they were whispering I'm gonna vote for
him because who cares about the moral
thing was kind of low on the totem pole
of issues that they had however Roy more
women won't tolerate a man who is dating
little girls and so that's kind of a
non-starter so but I mean yeah but he
still did they still did because in
Alabama right they're conditioned that's
a whole different mindset but I mean
really I can I let me let me just tell
you there is not there is nine out of
ten men have looked at or made a woman
who works for them feel uncomfortable in
a business setting we wear short you
wear a dress you wear it's not Donald
Trump it's Donald Trump late it's Donald
Trump like it's Donald Trump
not on Sarah it's not the guy that that
said it but it's it's the person who
makes you feel like that eight out of
ten women have been sexually absolutely
so I mean so it goes to the your you you
get used to how to how to navigate
that as opposed to person who is just
never gonna help you and you know I
think that women just rejected Hillary
Clinton as a whole if you look at the
numbers they didn't go out for Hillary
yeah not women white not some an
enormous amount of white overwhelming
majority of white educated women did not
vote for Hillary Clinton between the
ages of 30 35 and 50 55 right so and
what could what should she have done
then to appeal to those people so
Hillary Clinton during the convention so
I made my daughters and their friends
sit and watch her speech how old are
your daughters 14 12 14 11 insects and
so them and their friends I made them
all sit there I shut the lights off and
I said guys we're gonna watch something
and they're like oh cool they're gonna
watch and I put on the Democratic
convention just as Clinton was coming
out fun never ends oh yeah they were
like oh we're out of here I was like
nope you're all sitting down and they
told all your moms I was making watch
this so you're all watching us and she
gave her speech and when she was talking
about how she moved Chelsea into her
room and Stanford into the dorm and how
she pulled open the drawers and she was
cleaning everything out and putting all
her stuff away and I said see if that
Hillary Clinton plays through she wins
and that Hillary Clinton left that in
the convention hall and never what what
is that no it was it was a it was a
softer side it was a I understand I
understand what you're going through so
remember women in that age group that
she lost right are if you're a white
educated woman chances are you have a
career you're trying to do be the
superwoman you're trying to work you're
trying to have your family you're trying
to be everything and it's tough to do it
so you see a woman who's in power who
says I did it I did it all I I totally
get it I know how hard it is and that
day that I sent my baby off to college
and I you know it was so emotional for
me and you're gonna have those emotional
days that's actually that
actually is something that women can
understand and then that went away it
totally you know she she left it and
there was no emotion the rest of the
time and then you know it was the New
York City September 11th you know she
wasn't feeling well and instead of just
sitting down she lied about being sick
right so then it's like well now she's
not now she's lying about being sick why
cuz women can't be weak we can't we
can't be sick we can't be seen as not
feeling well and having to sit down and
I think that that is that is why we're
in this mess today in 2018 is because
there there haven't been women along the
way including her to stand up for other
women and say it's okay to have those
moments of weakness so she had that
moment of weakness at the convention and
then it was gone
I mean I'm gonna go out on a limb and
say you understand what it's like to be
a white woman better than I do but it it
seemed to me during the campaign that
she was in a sort of between a rock and
a hard place because when she would show
that then there would be pushback
against like well that's why we can't
have a woman as president well she did
win by three million votes right yeah
which you know and Bush when I worked
for Bush and we lost by half a million
ways to joke that like anybody gotta let
your present when you get more votes you
know takes professionals and lose about
half a million it's not so funny now it
is very very difficult statistically if
you just read it through to lose three
million votes and and when it's written
and still win the electoral college it
is just mathematically very very
difficult for that to happen the
probability politics is all about
probability assume and the probability
of that happening a very remote which is
why all the projections the polling
really wasn't that far off they had
Hillary Clinton winning pretty much for
tomorrow that she did it was just a
little bit of where she lost the was she
underperformed and I think that's an
important thing
to remember for Republicans you know
with the last time that we won the
popular vote in the presidential
election was 2004 2004 and that was the
only time since nineteen I you know I
did the Bush campaign the reelect and 80
yeah what did I say thank you yeah 88
sorry right so 88 88 oh four that's it
and I did 2004 and I mean one of the
things about Bush where I will say in
our favor was when you lose by half a
million you still get to win it's very
humbling and we never thought that we
had anything figured out and we always
approached it with great that this is
going to be very very difficult so on
election night in 2004 it was it really
came down to Ohio but it's very closely
held thing I mean if 75,000 votes to
change some minds we would have lost so
it's not like we attract some code and
it's it's just increasingly difficult to
be able to win those majorities and I
think it's very very important but they
don't debate about local college but
just sort of as a country I think it's
important for the person who gets the
most votes to win and that's that's I
think it can be a real challenge
before we order that the audience dan
have you your your three daughters are
all 5 or under have you talked to them
at all about politics today you have any
sense of what's happening not yet they
they say Donald Trump is bad it's pretty
much the extent of it nobody to to you
know to kind of good bring it back a
little bit I mean I think you know what
we're just kind of talking about you
know number one I'm an optimist
okay I think you know to paraphrase the
The Big Lebowski like nothing is f tear
dude
okay like we can so if you're a Democrat
and you want Donald Trump gone well
Michigan was 12,000 votes guys so 12,000
votes that's what you need to you know
that's 6,000 you take away you can fit
6,000 people in Michigan not to vote
6,001 6001 okay if you're a Democrat
that's your goal now if you're a
Republican I think it's important to
understand what is it about Trump that
appeals to those white working-class
voters well I'll tell you I mean I've
been around these you know I'm a white
working-class you know not anymore I'm a
doctor now but you know at one time I
was you know a white working-class
military and it is the chip on his
shoulder so if you want to save the
Republican Party you need to find
someone who fights someone who fights
without all the other stuff I mean you
know I was telling Stewart on the way
down
James Madison would kick the crap out of
Donald Trump in the heartland you know I
don't know if he's gonna run you know
probably not but you know the rock would
kick the crap out of Donald Trump in the
heartland you know but I mean that's
your challenge so you know what you know
the people he resonated with people for
some reason he resonated with folks who
grew up as part of an honor culture and
you know if you understand that you can
harness it for good
all right let's open it up for questions
we have two microphones if you could go
up to one of microphones and we are
recording this and then we also post a
transcript later so if you can just
identify yourself so we can then say who
you are instead of just random person
hey my name is Ron Newman and I'm a
left-wing Democrat from Somerville there
are people who would argue that the
trajectory that brought the Republican
Party to where it is now with that with
Trump started with Richard Nixon
Southern Strategy yeah in the 1960s when
the Republicans decided instead of
appealing to African Americans and you
know drawing on the history of how the
Republican Party got founded that they
instead thought it'll be better to
appeal to white racists do you agree
with this analysis and if you don't tell
me why you don't well southern
I'll jump into that you know before 6064
the Republican presidential candidates
could routinely get 30 to 35 percent of
the african-american vote which is not
great but you get to 35 you can kind of
see 40 get to 40 you know you're kind of
feeling better and then it fell off a
cliff and it's never come back
as an aside if the same thing is
happening with Hispanic voters
Republican Party Cougars in Bush we got
up to 43 percent in 2004 Trump and
Romney both got about 27 percent but
it's 27 27 percent of a increasing share
so if you got the same 27 you're getting
fewer votes
i I think that you have to sort of be
honest and if you're somebody like me
it's frankly difficult and painful that
there's a lot of truth to what you said
I think the great failure of the
Republican Party pre Trump was to appeal
to African American voters the modern
Republican Party and I work for a lot of
candidates who worked really hard to do
better and and it's frustrating and
there's an interesting phenomenon that
African American Republican candidates
don't tend to do better with African
Americans so it's not just a question of
having someone run it's I think it's a
moral imperative to acknowledge it and
to do better but I'll be damned if I
know the road to that is it is it not
appealing or was it not appealing to
African American voters or appealing to
white racists I mean you talked about
Mississippi burning and Reagan had the
famous Neshoba show became there where
he worried you know I I was there and I
grew up going in the Shelby County bears
I don't I might be naive about this I
did not see that fraught with symbolism
to go to the show Burt County no but to
go to Neshoba County and talk about
states rights yeah I don't know I don't
I I think it was to me it was different
than the tone the Trump is right but
that's and that's not even a low bar
that's like I mean I didn't I personally
I but it is so different than what made
in the Shelby County Fair what made the
Shelby County famous was the three civil
rights workers and Schwerner Chaney and
Goodman were buried in the Shelby County
though everyone from Shelby County will
point out that the people who did it
were not from the show I mean I don't
know I didn't I didn't see that as being
the dog whistle that it often is I mean
would you look at clinton-gore when they
ran different demo super-predators and
there was whistles on both sides stiffer
ground the Democrat turned out to be it
was like you know you were for the death
penalty we're gonna end welfare right
and they they campaigned with
Confederate flag I don't know I things
are never perfect so never one thing of
the other and I think degree matters a
lot
I mean Abe Lincoln is my favorite
president ever and so I for me I hold
out I'm an optimist I hold out hope in
the fact that we are not this racist
party and we are able to kind of come
out of this this was a temporary glitch
for us and I think that the way I know
the way I think it changes is by
electing more women to office because I
think if we start electing more women to
office and kind of generationally push
out some of the older members of
Congress bring in more women the
conversation changes and we can actually
the only way the Republican Party is
going to change if where it's starting
to appeal to women and minorities and
we're not doing a great job of it right
now
is the Republican Party racist I mean I
think right this is where we've led
right no but some of the people in it
are you know and and enough to elect
Donald Trump who's clearly racist yeah
hi Ron Jacobson I'm a night fellow at
MIT and a fellow Vermonter Dan's so you
just mentioned the rock kind of half
jokingly and I think that kind of begs
the question that whenever Donald Trump
exits the stage do things go back to
normal like normal politics or has are
we about to enter some brand new thing
that we can't even really predict what
it's gonna be yet like new career
politicians have a future running for
president
yeah you know I certainly hope so
I think that Trump is demonstrate you
know one of the one of the problems with
the Trump administration from the get-go
is you know it's a mature hour over
there right you know there's a dearth of
professional expertise and that's that
turns out to be really important you
know you can't have your son-in-law just
have the back-channel embassy
communications with the Soviets right so
you know it doesn't go back to you know
how it was before well you know I think
it will I think I think celebrity lends
an advantage to someone who's thinking
of running for office you know that but
I'd be curious what stories to say about
that yeah I mean and I'll just weigh in
when Oprah when it was rumored that
Oprah was going to run what I was
hearing from Democrats that I was oh god
I hope not
well I mean we see what having a
celebrity being in office does not that
Oprah is not a wonderful woman who has
had a great career but just I think that
we need to go back to governors and
Senators running for president and on
things yeah people that actually know I
mean you know whether you like my Mike
Pence or you don't like Mike Pence he's
been a member of Congress and he's been
a governor so you know he actually
understands policy and politics and I
think that that's he's one of the very
few people that's in there that actually
got said okay yeah good question
I am I'm Roger Wilson and
Republican and I I think Dan's really
onto something on the honor culture my
son was in the military and served in
Iraq and I identify it with what he's
saying but David Brooks had a column
recently saying that you guys are the
the never Trump folks have to address
the grievances or interests that are
that the Trump voter has in order to to
defeat Trump and I I would say honor the
honor culture that's an interest it's
it's a way people see their own
self-interest as their values but
there's also a whole set of more
substantive I think grievances that a
lot of people had when I attended the
caucus in Massachusetts was when I
thought Trump would would potentially
win and that was in the spring and the
Trump people were the most normal people
in the room in the Republican caucus
they were like Patriots fans you know
successful plumbers etc and the guy
leading the fight and they were very
well organized the guy leading the fight
was a ex-military guy had everybody
organized perfectly they got all the
delegates not only for for the trunk
vote but they voted Trump people into
all the other allocated delegates so
they they were really well organized and
that was in Massachusetts so I wonder
what you do you agree with David Brooks
do you have some ideas about beyond the
Honor interest
what other interests are not being
served by the establishment
that you would respond to and appeal to
the trunk voter well I mean one of the
ironies we talk about sure I think Trump
is is very much nothing worse that which
might get inherited oh yeah and here's
the guys it's inherited well and it's
why I don't think Trump really is a
populist I I think that you can get
those voters without the dark mr. Trump
brings I mean certainly when Bill well
ran in Massachusetts we got those voters
and when salucci ran I guess when it ran
I didn't work on it and it's covered
yeah so I think that there is a way to
speak to them that isn't about grievance
but about aspiration and I think that
it's an obligation in a civil society to
try to appeal to that which makes us
better not what knee you need to do to
win now I say that as someone who's just
been focused on winning for a lot of
years and a lot of races but I I don't
think if you ask those people are you do
you like what Trump said about women I
don't think I see very few of them would
at least admit it I don't think they do
they're like decent good people and
that's the danger of electing someone
like Trump because it begins to to use a
word that's used a lot normalize it and
I think these intangibles are very
important I think it's very important to
have role models that you can look at
and I disagreed with Barack Obama on a
lot of policy stuff
I worked against him but I think he's a
very admirable person I think he is and
you could look at Barack Obama and feel
better about America and feel and point
to him as someone you might disagree
with but this is a good and decent
family and I think that that those
little things are really important
and I don't you look at candidates
across the country and governors are
particularly good
no one's I don't very few people are
running like Donald Trump and I think
that's telling it's and when people like
Donald Trump for a run and they run they
tend to lose so he won yeah but they're
not a lot of them and I think that
that's telling so I think the fact that
Trump did win and does represent this
darkness it's not definitive that that
is the way to go to win my name is Doug
and I coach here at MIT full disclosure
I'm a registered Democrat just a quick
question I tend to be long-winded I'm
gonna try to be as succinct as I
possibly can but before I even say
anything just curious what does a panel
feel about what happened with the
Supreme Court pick I don't mean who was
picked I mean where do we find Obama is
know when the Senate refused to bring to
the floor right when Obama was president
correct I'm just curious how did you
guys feel about that
me personally it seemed like kind of a
violation of the the spirit of the of
the thing I mean I think the you know
what makes this all Americans or what
should make us all Americans and part of
the problem with the whole Trump thing
is you know our loyalty should be to the
rules of the game you know when you're a
military officer you take an oath to the
Constitution right so you know you you
have to you have to conduct yourself and
accept the results you know you have to
you know the chips fall where we're you
know and you play your hand so to me I
think it was kind of a low blow if you
want to use that term or what have you
yeah you know it's sudden
it's unfortunate politics right I mean
it's politics is a bloodsport and ya
know I know I'm not some other US
president where anything like that is
ever happy ya know I I mean look that
the Senate was in control they were able
to do what they wanted to do right and
they they decided that that was whether
it was right or wrong I don't agree with
what they did I think it was you know he
had he still had the right to make his
nomination and it should have been it
should have gone you know gone through
and Trump is gonna have plenty of time
to nominate other Supreme Court justices
did you did you say at the time that you
didn't agree with it you didn't say
anything publicly
you didn't say you disagreed with it I
mean I don't know if my opinion doesn't
matter I mean here in Massachusetts but
I mean I don't know if I said whether I
did or not I mean you know and sometimes
you look at it and say well it should be
up to the next person but did it happen
to flush it happened to did it happen
the closest is the 1800s in Congress no
but wasn't that was there an opening not
the closest is when Joe Biden famous
leaves yes that's right I disagree with
you about it frankly right right and I
think that was the one thing that I had
said was well Biden said it so I mean
you know if I didn't set it then Biden's
not vice president and so what's good
for the goose is good for the gander but
really proceed procedure procedurally it
should have been that at least you know
he went through I guess the reason why I
asked that because I think it speaks to
some of the problem you know I guess
because I studied in college I kind of
intimately know what was in the minds of
the framers of our Constitution more
than most and we're very lucky because I
don't think it would ever happen again
frankly but I think part of part of this
whole when it comes to politics and in
the way our society's moving is you have
to accept okay society's moving in this
direction and this is how it goes
but anyway so I was just curious I you
know I mean but I do I'm just a speaks
my next point
a big constitutionalist and I think of
it as it's separation of powers right so
the president could make his
recommendation the Senate is a separate
branch right so they can do whatever
they want with the judiciary you know
and the dish is very separate
so so realistically I mean if they
decide that they don't want if they want
to punt it for however long they want to
punt it for it doesn't look good it
doesn't smell good
it's also not what was intended that's
just not that's not how it was supposed
to work anyways I leaves in kind of my
point because I think part of the issue
in general you mentioned term limits
like personally I think you know that
that's a possible solution or part of
the solution but I think the biggest
issue is the never-ending campaign cycle
the fact that we're talking about 2020
not just now
we've been talking since before the
election was even over and the lobbyists
and the money in the campaign's
it's just it's just detrimental to the
entire practice so I guess my question
to the panel is also because you all
nodded your heads and you seem to agree
what I just said how did we get away
from that I think that is killing us
and frankly one thing that I thought
about this election is I thought whoever
won this election is going to lose the
next one we're overdue for an emic
economic crash etc who knows but just
the fact that we're all talking about
2020
who cares about 2020 I mean yeah let's
look down the road Amity but let's let's
focus on what our problems are now and
that's what we need to focus on it
because otherwise it's not work so I'll
step away from the mic here because I've
been talking too long but but another
question I guess is gonna have one of
the reason why I came to this forum is
you know I I'm glad to see people
Republicans who are not happy with
what's going on with the presidency a
lot of the Republicans I talked to just
keep on supporting Trump no matter what
which is extremely frustrating and they
keep on saying well it's better than
Hillary it's like I don't care who won
the election let's just pay attention to
what's happening now don't just because
you're not happy or just because it's
okay to say you're not happy with what's
going on and you vote if that person
that's okay you know let's let's try to
fix what's going on because I think more
of us if we admit it to ourselves we
might be able to do something about it
but I guess so that's my question is
what are you guys gonna do you guys have
the keys to everything your control of
everything
I mean controls everything when I say
Republicans and one thing as much as his
politics actually frightened me more and
his policies and fiscal policies and his
political views I would much rather have
Mike Pence in there and impeach this
president because I don't think he's
gonna get us in a nuclear war and he
does have some sort of understanding of
the process and understands that you
know you can't just be firing off
Twitter
you know think so I guess my question to
you guys that I leave is what are we
gonna do about it because this is a real
problem
I would I would support federal funding
for all Federal Elections I've really
become radicalized on this you know
there seems to be about ten of us in the
country so it's not looking good and
campaign finance is one of these things
if you think about it for five minutes
it seems easy and if you think about for
15 it seems impossible because there's a
lot of arguments on both sides and a lot
of laws of unintended consequences but
I've worked in a lot of other countries
and look at different systems and I
would go to a federal funding for all
federal elections with limits and I go
back to term limits because if you limit
the US Senate to two terms that's 12
years in term number two they stopped
going out with the lobbyists they
stopped you know being wined and dined
they don't need to do the fundraising
they don't need the special interest so
I think that term limit solves a lot of
it plus you get turnover getting new
ideas is always good again you know any
company even a university someone's
tenured someone else comes in if you're
in a company someone's that an associate
moves up the ladder and that's really
healthy and good to continuously have
new blood come in which we don't have
unless there are vacancies or someone is
actually beatable
yeah well you know what's what you run
again you know 12 years later or eight
years later but I mean I think that that
actually it regenerates itself a lot by
being able to do that Tom hi I'm Tom
Levinson I'm a professor here I am a
Yellow Dog Democrat and first thing is I
want to say thank you to the panel
because even though I think I disagree
on almost everything good
the Republicans have attempted to do and
are doing over many years I think
there's plenty of empirical evidence
that almost all the policy choices are
bad you know a we need two parties
functioning and B it's you know it's not
easy being a Republican opposing not
just the president but the entire
leadership apparatus and I we need all
hands on deck if this you know it's not
just a dark moment for the Republican
Party its dark moment for the country
and I'm very glad you're you're doing
what you're doing here and and attending
your other work but I mean perhaps it's
because I'm Yellow Dog Democrat it seems
like the pathology of the Republican
Party is because it has been something
that you know it's not just that the
issue of race was became a problem in 68
you know the the the sort of you know
the effect of the same amount you know
it's like it's it's like a habituation
to a drug you know sort of dog whistling
in 68 becomes you know bowlegged
Mexicans with water you know you know
etc to all the horrible things that that
you know King of Iowa and others have
been saying and Trump is amplified you
know and and on and on through a number
of the issues that that the Republicans
have the Republican official party the
the platform a large number of
candidates have signed on to has been a
real you know that that's been growing
and growing and growing and frankly the
talent in the party I mean you talk
about
Democrats having nobody to run you know
that that gang of 16 wasn't exactly
enormous ly impressive I have to say and
you have people you know you've had
during the Obama years you had people
being rewarded for both awful and obtuse
things like the Benghazi nonsense and so
on and so forth so I gotta ask you I
know it's really hard to leave a
childhood faith as it were but you
haven't convinced you haven't been
convincing tonight that the Republican
Party is either saving or worth is
savable or worth saving and I guess I
want to ask you is how seriously you've
considered you know whether or not the
Republicans are now where the pre-war
Democrats were in 18 you know fifty
eight nine and whether something else
has to be done
well if Donald Trump is the Republican
Party it's not a party that I would be
drawn to it think it up to voters to
decide what the Republican Party is
going to be I think this talent question
that you either the point that you made
I think it's a very good one and if the
Republican Party becomes a party that is
the anti-science party that is the white
grievance party that is a party that
isn't for aspirational education they'll
have a resentment toward those who are
educated and that instead of aspiring to
be better educated you're basically
against the future because the future
ultimately doesn't care what you think
it's going to happen and you know if
you're against the future at some point
you're going to lose and you're not
going to become relevant and I think
that's the essential point question for
the party what is its relevance and you
turn on Fox and you get a sense that
maybe Hillary Clinton's going to lose
the election it's it's not really
relevant to anything that is about the
future and that's what the party has to
decide I mean the party at its heyday
was founded as a poor not founded but in
the modern party at its heyday feel like
it Reagan and 144 states you know what
did that party stand for in many ways
the party you could argued some have
articulate very eloquently did the
party's a victim of its own success that
it was the crime is down it was a it was
a law-and-order party it was a anti
Soviet Union Party stand up to them
there's no more Soviet Union it was
a party that felt that will fair had
gone to an extreme and will fare
certainly thanks to Bill Clinton has
changed and there are a lot of those
issues that you won
so then what else are you going to
that's the great challenge what are you
going to be for I know in 2000 and the
Bush campaign really the only thing that
we did that worked I mean I'm talking
about sitting there watching numbers was
restoring honor and dignity to the White
House
we put tax stuff up there it didn't move
a thing and it was about this question
of character and I think that that's
really what the party has to decide what
it wants to be and we always say that
you have to stand for something other
than an election and now you have to
sort of see if you really believe that
so I had I became a Republican to the
dismay of my retired bus driver Union
grandfather and my seamstress Union
grandmother who we lived with they were
horrified and it was because I worked my
butt off and I saw kids around me
getting handouts and I was pissed
because my dad died and I got nothing
and I didn't have a parent and for me it
was being a Republican was all about
hard work it was all about if you work
hard you get rewarded it was about
limited government and people saying out
of your business and I'm inherently a 16
year old girl that doesn't want anyone
to tell me what to do so don't tell me
what to do with my money don't tell me
what to do with my body just leave me
alone and go on your merry way and so I
won and a Republican I'm never I won't
change that regardless of who the
president
and how much I disagree with them what I
will do is teach my kids and my kids
friends about what the party actually
stands for is supposed to stand for and
to fight to get it back and I think that
you know one of the challenges is to
make sure that people fight for what
they believe in and really believe in
and stop laying down and let people
running run over us with their own
beliefs and so what's happening right
now is a lot of us feel like we were
mowed down and I just keep saying well
it's like whack-a-mole like hit me down
come back up and hit me down come back I
really don't care I'm gonna still still
be here as a thorn in your side but I
don't I'm not a Democrat I don't believe
in the principle so I'm not gonna change
over to the left but I I think that our
party needs to get back to what we
believe in the the tax what just
happened and and the deficit and the
budget that went through I mean it's
like you want to vomit
we're leaving my kids and grandkids all
of our kids and grandkids with such
enormous debt that how do you even get
out of it none of us would have a credit
card bill laying around like that how we
leave that for our kids so anyway
but I didn't ask you if you've become a
Democrat I asked you if if the
Republican Party as it is not as you
wish it to be but as it is aspire to
what do you do about that hey if I get
elected and taxco I said most recent tax
bill is so will Caray Cambridge will
carry cam Burton are any people's
Republican Cambridge so again I think
the only way comes back Donald Trump is
completely generationally different than
I am right I'm gonna be here a lot
longer than he is and so hope to God and
I created three other beings like myself
that are generationally substantially
different than me so you know my feeling
is if each of us can affect one other
life and change one of their life to go
out there and fight for what we believe
in then the world can be a better place
and so my belief is if I can take out
all of the elderly white racist males
and and replace them with you know women
younger women who actually have an idea
of what goes on in the world and what's
needed we're going to change the party
over and over it's not it's not stuck I
don't believe it's stuck Donald Trump is
only a temporary little glitch on the
radar screen he's out and then there's
another generation that will by the time
he
out be so pissed off that they're going
to motivate and change what the party
looks like that's my hope
I was gonna say preface my answer with
I'm not a Republican but I'm not a
Democrat either but the you know I I
think the Republican party looking at it
from the outside it's a conservative
party and if you want to sort of rebrand
republicanism you know you need to get
back to the back to the basics I mean
there's plenty about America that is
should be conserved
there's plenty that's great about our
country that should be conserved
you know the thing that's always one
thing that's always baffled me about you
know kind of how the political parties
align themselves I mean you know for
example the environment you know a
conservative should want to conserve the
environment you know things like that
you know there's plenty that is good and
wonderful about America and I believe
that and I think most of the people in
this room probably believe that too and
you know and conserving what is good is
how the Republican Party gets back to
business
yeah great thanks I'm not here to beat
up on you but I actually I may ask you
to elaborate on kind of some of these
earlier points my name is roll Wagner
MIT of alone now I'm working in
California and technology and that kind
of gives rise to some like some of the
perspective that I was bring or I drew
bring you know during the 2016 election
there was a lot of talk about coal
miners and you know coal jobs and
meanwhile in Silicon Valley we're saying
like well what about the 20 to 30
million jobs that isn't gonna disappear
from like self-driving trucks you know
just seeing yesterday that in terms of
party affiliate or party
I guess affiliation looking at the
breakdown looking at Millennials in
particular millennial women there's a
47% difference so you're talking about
75% to 25% in terms of party affiliation
so really curious building on the last
question you know I heard Stewart you
mentioning some of the core values
around individual responsibility
freedom Jennifer you mentioning like
hard work and being able to see the sort
of results of your hard work and then
Daniel like talking about you know
communities where there's a real focus
on honor I'm curious like what are you
seeing like like policies or are you
seeing like how like what kind of
messages do you think would appeal to
well I wouldn't really speak to you know
the techies in California the
Millennials who are looking at you know
who just take for granted you know gay
marriage take for granted like you know
legal marijuana take for granted you
know working interacting with folks who
may not be documented like what what do
you see as a kind of um how do you see
that these ideals might be embodied in
messages that kind of resonate for for
these folks
so you're specific I'm going know I mean
I'd this whole I am absolutely baffled
by this meeting up of California they
Trump resent I mean California first of
all you know you take a state like
Mississippi we had for tax dollars back
for everyone we give so without
California Mississippi sort of blow away
and it's the single most successful
state without a doubt I mean it's it's
huge it's problematic but I mean it is
and has long and body's sort of the
future of America and I'll just go back
to that you have to embrace this and it
people that work in these diverse
communities as you know you know well
are not frightened by this this idea for
the most part there's always exceptions
it's it's this other Nastase fear of the
unknown this fear of the future that I
think that the Republican Party has to
get away from any party does if it's
going to exist
I'm not as optimistic personally I'd
like to be but I'm not as optimistic
because I don't necessarily see the path
clearly forward but I'm wrong as well I
see the path forward for the country or
for the party and for the party I mean I
just look at the numbers so Trump is a
twenty percent favorable among under 30s
if Trump is president they you know just
six years and then it's not just going
to be if even if Trump lost in 2020 to a
Democrat the Trump element of the party
is going to be there to deal with and I
think it's it's it's very troubling and
and I'm all for fighting and I love the
fight and I fight a lot but I'm very
sober about the prospect of it I mean I
almost want to offer reassurance I mean
the the values that all three of you
articulate I think are really powerful
and really compelling and it's I mean
you know you mentioning individual
freedom individual responsibility for me
is just this kind of curiosity about
what them I look like you know in mess
political messages Tanner or twenty
years down the road it's a really good
question yeah I think generationally had
changes I mean I just think that once
Trump is gone he surrounded himself by
men that wanted to retire and this was
the last hurrah in their careers as we
see they're being shuffled out you know
daily and I think that by the time he's
done he's gonna have gone through all of
them and it's just gonna be there's not
gonna be any other you know billionaire
way you know 78 year old to be hanging
out in the cabinet anymore and I think
that you know we are again it's going to
be a turnover and you see by the numbers
of women historical numbers of women are
running in 2018 for seats whether they
win or lose it doesn't matter women are
now mobilized and women do you see that
there's in me
to start getting involved and I think
that that's how it changes because you
know I always laugh like my my recycling
is like the neatest recycling in the
entire world I rinse everything my kids
are nuts about it would not that we we
take care of everything right and I when
you know people say that there's no
climate change in the party and then
it's February and I'm walking around in
flip-flops because it's 70 degrees on a
random day in New England and so I think
that it's just going to take a new
generation to come up there I mean and
that's maybe it's like I'm 46 so for me
you know I left I'm young in my business
until I'm like 60 so I feel like there's
still plenty of time for people like
myself and younger to make changes in
the party going forward and and have
real appreciation for technology howdy
was talking about coal miners like my
great grandfather worked in a coal mine
that's antiquated going forward is what
your business and what you're up to I
agree with all that yeah hi my name is
David Wu I'm an undergrad at MIT so
Jennifer like you I think that in the
way things are going Trump's gonna win
again and I'd really not like to have
six more years of that so the only way
that I see that happening is moderates
from both sides come together and agree
on some fundamental principles about
what we want in our government and I'm I
can understand how like college educated
voters also voted for Trump and I
understand that in 2016 and I think the
goal should be to try to convince them
not to vote again the next time around
and I think that you've you sexist a lot
and you've thrown out and I totally
agree with you his comments
despicable like unacceptable but I think
in terms of a unifying
way of convincing moderate Republicans
to go away from Trump that these attacks
on Donald Trump's character are not the
most effective way because then you're
implying that voters who voted for Trump
also share some of these characteristics
and I definitely know that's not true
I've friends and parents of friends who
voted for Donald Trump and I will speak
to their character and it's not true and
I think it's almost harmful if we just
use these emotional appeals all the time
like the undermining of the justice
system and we were supposed to have
separation of powers if you believe in
the American government system we're
supposed to have separation of powers
and the constant undermining of the
judicial system the constant undermining
of the freedom of the press is a huge to
huge fundamental issues that I think
everyone if you believe in the American
government system can support there's
fake news you don't need to believe the
news you can read multiple news sources
so this fake news nonsense has been just
like I don't understand it all just read
multiple sources if you want a whole
picture on something so do you think if
you just stick to these principles of
separation of powers believing the
Constitution the freedom of the press
these tariffs and these trade wars I
don't think have ever helped the
consumer the economy in the history of
America do you think if you just stick
to those three principles it's enough to
get moderate Republicans and moderate
Democrats decide together or now in this
social media age is where everything's
in a tweet and everything's in a
10-second video clip do you think that
message will get lost in
there's no honestly no hope so I'm just
gonna start cuz I I think he's a sexist
I don't think that that's a winning
message
no thank you I agree with him again in
full disclosure my mother not only did
she vote for Donald Trump which was late
Oh God not only did she vote for him
that's fine that she voted for him but
she is like I can't talk to her if I
disagree with
one thing that truck so my problem with
her voting for him was not that she
voted for Trump because I have lots of
friends that voted for him it would it's
her adamancy about you know well mom you
have granddaughters would you want him
to talk about them like that mom you
were a single woman you worked in a
business with lots of men you were men
came on to you it's like none of that
actually even matters to her and she
just she loves Donald Trump so I mean
the sexism thing is my own hang-up about
him but I think that there are there are
people on both sides of the aisle that
would really like to see they didn't
like Bernie Sanders and they didn't like
any of the Republicans and there has to
be a more moderate message the problem
is the primary system
yeah the primary system pulls everyone
to the right and everyone to the left
and then they lose I mean that was one
of the problems with Hillary was that
because she was going against Bernie she
got pulled so far to the left that it
was very difficult for her to find where
she was always playing kind of in the
middle and so we need a message like
that I mean I think what's going on now
with the tariffs and the trade war once
that starts hurting middle America that
will define a message really quickly
hi at birching or a faculty member here
i have a question about the possibility
for depolarization there's been a lot of
discussion around values and the hope
that perhaps values can be that there
exists perhaps a political or cross pull
it across party values that might bring
people together and of course I remember
a time 20 years ago 40 years ago when
comedy was celebrated practice certainly
at least within the Senate and we did
have a primary system back then one
thing I've observed is that a lot of
people on the left reacting to Trump are
doing so in a values framework
particularly young people is there a
prospect for people to come together
with with concepts of basic values and
you've enumerated a great set that I
think would cross the political spectrum
for diminishing some of this extreme
polarization that we have and bringing
us back to a little bit of cross-party
comedy but then I don't think this is a
lot of what Europe yeah yeah you know I
think excuse me I think you know the
common experience you know the entire
you know idea of the organization that
we've started was that common experience
is going to trump you know sort of
different part in the pond but you know
the difference the differences you know
so so you know what what I think you
know about veterans and veterans coming
home is we all have this shared
experience of serving in the military
not everyone not all veterans have been
in combat you know but we all at least
have that shared experience of having
been sort of inqalab in these values
inculcated into us and the importance of
a team and you know the team is more
important than itself there are other
things like that you know there's you
know it's the commonalities that you
know I think you need to sort of be
emphasized and
and I think that that is possible I mean
I think young people have a lot more in
common with each other whether they're
on the left or the right than they do
with their grandparents you know and I
think that you know some of the
generational factors are going to going
to work there and so yes I do think
there's a way for but it but it like all
of these things it takes work you know
this is you know someone needs to stand
up and you know reach across the aisle
and be the first one to do it and then
be the second one to do it and then be
the third one to do it and that is not
happening right now I think we have time
for one more question Bradley thank you
my name is Cecilia Buren I'm a visiting
fellow at MIT from Norway representing a
small group of Norwegian heritage so we
find was very interesting because well
Trump is also kind of a president for us
because City u.s. is our big brother in
many ways and I think it was quite a
shock when we woke up in the morning and
found out that what seemed to be
impossible actually happened and it has
changed also the way politics is done in
Norway and the view we have from the
world and that this is more question to
all three of you because I do realize
that probably foreign policy is not the
most important concern for in politics
in the US but on the other hand we are
used for the president of the u.s. to be
a stabilizing factor also for us what we
see now is that it's the total opposite
and I was living in a time where we were
squeezed between the Soviet Union and
the US and we were afraid of nuclear war
worse than you are probably the same
that we learned how to protect ourselves
how to get down on the floor and
whatever to protect yourself for nuclear
weapons but what we see now is that the
new generation actually is starting to
get afraid of exactly the same things
that we thought were gone for so many
years
so is this an issue in the US or could
it be an issue and will it have any
impact or could it have any impact in
the next election
well statistically foreign policy right
is not a big election you know before in
2012 when I was running for the Romney
campaign though there was three debates
between the Obama and Romney and the
third was supposed to focus on foreign
policy did focus on foreign policy so we
just did a poll before how many people
are interested in and in only 7% thought
it was one of their top ten issues what
else like in a way you know in a way you
can argue that's that's positive and
that when we tend to be involved in
foreign policy is when we're fighting a
war certainly in Vietnam those numbers
would have been very different and I
think at the beginning of the Iraq
invasion certainly it would have been
different but I think one of the great
disasters of Trump is his failure to
understand or appreciate the Stu need
for stability in the world and the US
central role in that and that we've the
whole post-war alliance that we have
built that has kept peace for the most
part I think is in jeopardy and it is
you can put all of this stuff together
and that could very well be the most
troubling and lasting legacy of Chuck
and I don't see him he has an
extraordinary inability to learn
and most presidents get better but he's
not and that doesn't bode well before we
m11 I guess I'll reserve my right is
moderator to ask one final question
before he signed the Civil Rights Act
the LBJ famously said that he was he was
gonna lose this out for Democrats for
generations to come
which in many ways ended up being true
Meneses airy for a Republican leader to
make a similar type of principled stand
where they say that short term political
calculus is going to be against this but
I'm gonna do this for the identity of
the party and a corollary to that
question is what would that stand be
well I think in many ways this is what
Mitt Romney did when he gave the speech
with Donald Trump there's certainly
nothing in it for him and I have been
surprised and saddened did more of that
hasn't happened I I think it's a great
failure of this moment and I think we'll
look back on it and ask that same
question why it didn't because I think
it'll seem very obvious it'll seem very
obvious say it should have happened or
it'll should have had I I don't have a
good answer for that I don't I don't
know I don't know if it'll be forced by
a crisis
you know I don't know yeah I mean I
think that you know you saw Lisa
Murkowski
and Susan Collins Lindsey Graham John
McCain I mean you know to me they're
heroes faith that they stood up when no
one else was standing up to say this is
wrong and we're not agreeing you know
health care or Rubio Lindsey Graham
Grassley you know the whole on the
Mueller I I think also it's gonna take
some kind of unfortunate tragedy for
anyone else to to find the nerve to
stand up and it's really concerning
because I was married on September 8th
of 2001 I was one of the 30 flights in
the air on September 11th I couldn't
land because we were over the Pacific
Ocean
so I landed on my honeymoon finding out
that New York was never gonna be the
same I grew up in New York 78 people
from my hometown died that day tons of
our friends were in the Trade Center
friends of mine were pregnant jumping on
the back of garbage trucks to get out of
town so like that is an actual serious
real real feeling that I have and a
concern that I have that you know
raising kids in this crazy world what
happens and so I think that that's when
people stand up and finally realize and
get out of their bubbles but I mean I
mend our leaders who have been out there
in the forefront saying that stuff
shouldn't happen because it takes a lot
for them and they take a lot of blowback
for it I think I think yes but you know
someone needs to stand up but I I don't
think that a politician I don't think
there's a politician in the Republican
Party who you know can challenge a
sitting president and just flip the
switch like that I think it has
be another public figure and you know
that there are plenty of folks that you
know the average Republican voter I
think trust more than Donald Trump's you
know when when Billy Graham you know
gets up and says it I guess he won't
anymore but you know well you know
someone like that says it you know there
was this tipping point in Vietnam right
where you know Walter Cronkite said all
you know I'm not sure we can win this
anymore that's the moment that needs to
happen and that's you know that's that
was a news anchor that was not a
politician I was not sure Johnson said
if we lost Cronk if we lost cross
country you know so I think that you
know when Fox and Friends say that
they're you know that's that's the
moment that needs to happen I think it's
a scary thought to leave us on that
we're looking at the Fox and Friends to
be the world chorus that well thank you
you three so much for coming out this
was a really rewarding conversation
thank you all for coming out also I'm
sorry if we didn't get a chance to ask
your questions as I said this will be up
online and a couple of days and
hopefully we can continue the
conversation
[Applause]